los familiares de las víctimas lloraban
y se abrazaban en los pasillos de la
corte cuando condenaron a patricios el
autoproclamado nacionalista blanco que
mató a 23 personas en una tienda de
Walmart en El Paso Texas porque
supuestamente los latinos estaban
invadiendo Estados Unidos tendrá que
pagar 90 cadenas perpetuas consecutivas
es decir pasará el tiempo que le queda
de vida en la cárcel por crímenes de
odio varios de los familiares de las
víctimas esperaban que el atacante fuera
sentenciado a muerte y los fiscales
buscarán su pena de muerte precisamente
cuando el asesino sea juzgado en octubre
o noviembre por un tribunal Estatal por
su parte el abogado de el supremacista
blanco dijo que su cliente padecía de
una enfermedad mental grave cuando
cometió los delitos sin embargo uno de
los fiscales Ian Martínez Jana fiscal
adjunto de los Estados Unidos rechazó
esa idea y dijo que el asesino estaba
motivado por una ideología de odio dijo
que
crucis planeó el ataque con mucha
anticipación compró un rifle seis
semanas antes del ataque y condujo hasta
diez horas para llegar a un lugar donde
había gran cantidad de hispanos cabe
mencionar que 15 minutos antes de el
ataque crucis publicó en internet un
manifiesto lleno de odio que defendía
los supremacistas blancos diciendo que
las personas ricas y poderosas
facilitaban la inmigración de negros y
latinos para cambiar la población Blanca
por estas mi